you ever hang out with like a new group
of friends you don't usually hang out
with them and they all have a bunch of
inside jokes that you have no
uh understanding of and you're just kind
of standing there awkwardly
i feel like that's what it's like to
experience your first time in discworld
introduction hi everybody um i was
bullied by a bunch of bullies into
reading discworld
went online i read the charts about
what's the best place to enter
you know a lot of people say like the
night watch series is the best or the
the witches
anyways i felt like going through death
because it was um
no reason i started with more it seems
fun there's this character of death
and he has an apprentice okay let's do
it first off i like this book
some of it was a lot of fun but i feel
like most of it was me
figuring out what is the tone of this
there are fans who
say mort is great i believe it's the
fourth book in the series they say mort
is great
great place to start some say it's still
early discworld where
the the world hasn't gotten big enough
to encompass these you know deeper
themes it's more of kind of like a
parody of fantasy stories and
and that was my general experience a lot
of mort was kind of just like
riffing on fantasy stories in general
you know there will be like
digressions about like oh well wizards
have to have this kind of hat because if
you don't have this kind of hat you're
not a wizard and you gotta you know
it's very um cute a good
and a bad thing i guess depending on how
you want to look at it you know i
thought it was like okay this is fun it
felt
white but also like okay i don't really
care about any of these characters
you know what it reminded me of it
reminded me of like older mel brooks
or like spaceballs but what really
hooked me and what kept me reading this
book
was the little bits of philosophy
and like insightful moments and
ideas and implications i'm not doing any
spoilers for this
but this concept about the universe
repairing itself something in the
timeline is
put out of whack then the universe is
going to naturally repair itself it may
be slow but it's going to get back to
this
unalterable course of history which is
kind of wild you know is there any free
will
in discworld history really unalterable
things going on with death and what
happens to people after death some
people
fade there's one character who
reincarnates
death is really a fun character because
he
is kind of having an existential crisis
for me the most
fun was seeing mort kind of be consumed
by this role
as death's apprentice what i wish
for more strangely enough was more
seriousness
which is kind of a stupid thing to ask
for in a pratchett
book i love the humor i love the jokes
and
everything but it felt like it would
have been more fun
if i felt really tethered to the
characters in the in
to the characters and the characters
felt really realistic and i was really
invested in their character development
it's a combination of like this was fun
and light but also a little too light i
wanted a little more
just like character depth and story
depth i thought it shined the most in
the dialogue i loved
the the witty just the banter between
characters
some of the comedy just felt a little
dated a lot of it works and it's still
fun but yeah there are some
dated things there's one joke that is
based on the
idea that you know what sitting beside
someone listening to a walkman sounds
like
you know it was like a walkman joke and
i was like okay yeah this is definitely
came out in the 80s basically
what i'm saying is i'm gonna finish uh
what do i say i'm gonna finish the
series i'm gonna keep reading the series
that's what i'm trying to say
i really want to read guards guards
i might do that next or moving pictures
i definitely enjoyed my first terry
pratchett experience
i'm actually curious for those who love
pratchett what book should i read next
also what are the essential discworld
books in your opinion
i love just diving headfirst into a
vastly
just a vast and complicated series yeah
i'm
i'm happy i'm i want to continue and um
thank you for bullying me
you